go to hector mejia who's live with some
life-saving reminders from our local
fire department
good morning hector it's getting to be
that time of year isn't it
it really is and here are these
reminders all over again especially for
people who are new here in town so the
temperatures here
come with some dangers and the
temperature inside of a car
can become deadly in a matter of minutes
so never leave children
pets the elderly alone inside of a car
without the ac
on officials say if you see a person or
pet inside
of a car you are obligated by law to
dial 9-1-1
you should stay on scene and help guide
first responders by waving your arms
las vegas fire and rescue says we need
to remember we live in one of the
hottest
cities in the united states with a lot
of newcomers moving into town
they want to drive home that message
sometimes people have the misconception
that
if you have tinted windows it will act
like the shade
and make the interior of the car cooler
and actually
that is incorrect it's just the opposite
it makes the interior of the car
hotter we're told a car basically
functions like a greenhouse the dark
glass will heat up really fast and
it'll transmit the heat to the inside of
a car so the vast majority of cases
involving children
left in hot cars are accidental so look
before you lock you can leave things
like your cell phone a purse maybe even
a
man purse or even your shoe next to your
child
so you have a reminder and you look
before you walk away
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now